in quarantine session where you know
we're doing all of this sort of stuff
electronically and in the past we had
the option at least for those of us who
are local of meeting face to face for
things but now we're all more or less in
the same boat or really ought to be for
practicing what we're supposed to do so
looks like there's a lot of questions
there for me already I'll start going at
them and let's see what we've got here
first so ultra Peter asks can i comment
on Nietzsche's criticism of the American
work ethic in the gay science and has a
follow-up is there a difference in the
attitude towards work ethic and
catholicism and protestantism so
Nietzsche you know Nietzsche himself
didn't care an awful lot about the
Americans but he did think that any
expressed this in in multiple points
what we often think of as the
prototypical American work ethic which
is you know you work all the time and
you're you know you're valued in terms
of your work he saw that starting to
trickle into Europe and he thought that
that was a bad thing and so he thought
that this this notion that we have to be
accountable all the time I mean you see
some of this in the people today who are
all about hustling during the
coronavirus crisis there's that meme of
that guy going around saying if you
haven't done this and haven't done this
and haven't done this and started a
business by the time the crisis finishes
you're you're you know you lack
discipline well that would be exactly
the sort of thing that nature would say
is problematic and you know it's
interesting so you know you're not
asking about for example rainer maria
rilke but i'm gonna bring him up anyway
because he and nature both talked about
the term solitude itens um kite
something i'm actually going to be doing
a presentation on for the stoah two
Saturdays from now so you know it's not
just being by yourself but cultivating
something within you that allows you to
be
on your own that is what these these
thinkers thought of as as solitude in an
important sense can also be translated
by the way is loneliness but that's a
different notion there and so Nietzsche
thought that you know we need to be able
to have what you might call unprogrammed
time in order to live a decent life and
this always on the move always on the
make over scheduling ourselves sort of
attitude towards things is actually not
good for the human being whether you
want to call it the soul or of course
Nietzsche is a materialist so the spirit
comes out of the body but it still does
think that we're not just simply
reducible to our bodies so that's
something quite valuable is there a
difference between Protestant and
Catholic work ethics you should always
avoid when you're looking at religious
studies you should always avoid Catholic
versus Protestant to anything because
Protestants are such a motley mix across
the board even just in their beginnings
not to mention in the present today and
Catholics aren't all of one piece you
know Weber has that Protestant work
ethic and spirit of capitalism and
there's something to that but he's not
talking about all Protestants he's
talking in particular about the reformed
and Lutheran traditions and you know
there's there's interesting work done by
anthropologists who then said well does
this apply to say you know low church
Protestants in the American South or or
not you know and and so you've got to
avoid making massive generalizations
like that you can find Protestants and
Catholics who are incredibly unmotivated
and lazy and you can find Catholics and
Protestants who think that the entire
world should consist of work you can
find everything in between so I wouldn't
say that there's there's a fundamental
difference between those in terms of
those denominational divides all right
Caesar I am Caesar asks are you going to
make more esoteric videos about artworks
can you make one about Walter Benjamin's
idea of an artwork aura
so I don't do esoteric stuff you might
mean something different by esoteric
than I do for me esoteric is sort of
like mystic it's one of those ambiguous
terms and I'm not particularly
interested in esoteric stuff and I'm not
particularly interested in in trying to
like you know call out that I think that
esotericism is actually kind of you know
there's there's all sorts of projects
like yeah dad ain't for me I'm
interested in looking at what's actually
in texts not reading a whole bunch of
stuff into them or trying to find the
hidden meaning it's enough to actually
find the meaning that's that's in there
that we can we can more or less agree
upon would I do something I'm Walter
benjamine yeah but he is not high on my
list of priorities you know as I've
always said I prioritize videos for my
current students when I'm teaching and
so like this month I'm shooting some
stuff on MacIntyre and some stuff on
Cicero and we'll see what else MANET
while William James because those are
the immediate needs Ben you mean is is
somebody who is interesting but you know
I'm not a specialist in him and I don't
teach him in my my classes so Cynthia
says thank you very nice Thank You
Cynthia glad to be of help
URI I think it's how it's pronounced
what are my thoughts on the importance
of myths in Plato's dialogues well
that's a good question
so as Socrates himself says in the
Republic we make recourse to myths when
we sort of run out of the you know
rational dialectical account and you'll
notice that that Plato uses myths
basically in two ways one is it
precisely that you know we use them to
sort of speculate once we get beyond the
realm by some sort of symbolic
representation of things and their myths
start to blend into allegories right so
you know is is for example
the discussion of the chariot as the
sole in the Phaedrus is that
mythological yeah kind of you know on
the gods are being mentioned but it's
all within a sort of platonic framework
right it's not you know that's the other
thing too
Plato plays around with and transforms
traditional myths it's it's a mistake to
try to read Plato in terms of the
framework that that traditional
mythology which was always a
heterogenous can amass it was never like
all on one page it's a it's a mistake to
try to read rationalist played out from
that perspective into it's that that
whole thing or their own sake right that
said there is a very strong religious
dimension to to platonism there always
has been and so you know it's kind of
kind of cool to think about that I you
know it's interesting too I did this
project with a student years and years
back when I was an assistant professor
at Fayetteville State University and
they were doing this this research thing
you know trying to hook up very ahead of
the curve students with professors who
would be willing to help them carry out
research and so one of my students who
other you know if it wasn't for the fact
that her husband died while she was in
the process of doing this she you know
her husband was was in the 82nd airborne
Fayetteville State University's right
right by Fort Bragg she probably would
have actually gotten this done and and
you know gone ship conference and
actually presented it and then written
an article and so it was about you know
the myths of the afterlife in Plato and
we looked at all of them and we're
mapping them out and they don't all map
on to each other perfectly well you know
so they're there to make us think
they're not there to provide us with the
answers to everything I would say all
right Nazim asks dr. Sadler how do you
reconcile Providence and divine
immutability with with genuine human
freedom well you know the same way that
augustine and boëthius and Anselm do you
know
I think that God created human beings
with free wills and that's part of what
it means to be that kind of thing and
you know you know I buy into the
eternalism sort of metaphysics so that I
don't have any problem with looking at
things that way myself not everybody
does but we don't all have to agree on
metaphysics all we have to do is
acknowledge that whatever metaphysical
stance we pick it's not you know like
the nature of things imposed it upon us
that involves some choice on our parts
and different metaphysics come with you
might say different implications and
commitments all right Ken Blackwell says
I find most original works on stoicism
to be fairly easy to read Marcus
Aurelius Seneca epictetus and others the
exception is Missoni estroux ffice is
there a primer that I could recommend I
do believe that the book that you can
get his lectures and fragments in does
include like a lengthy forward it's
Cynthia somebody it was the translator I
believe right so you know I would take a
look at that and I would I would
actually go to Google Scholar and and
you know plunk Musso Gnaeus Rufus in
there and just see what pops up there
might be some some decent article
Laghman teri I mean it's interesting
stuff you know you notice that I've I've
cited him like in my discussion of
stoicism and relationships and I bring
him up when it comes to stoicism and in
accordance with nature right so you know
that's that's those are some starting
points that you might check out let's
see what else we've got here Nathan says
I'm gonna do some maths while I wait
okay well that that's always good to do
Lucas did Nietzsche actually believe in
the eternal return or did he only use it
as a metaphor or thought experiment so
this is this is a question on which
Nietzsche scholarship is quite divided
my personal view is that the eternal
recurrence of the same is not
particularly
really important within the scope of
Nietzsche's work will to power as a you
know I agree with like say Heidegger for
example will to power is much more
central metaphysical notion and I do
think it's it's really sort of a thought
experiment and a point there are some
people out there who are really
attracted to the idea and so they try to
blow it up into like the hermeneutic
principle to read nature through but I
just met I don't find that convincing
you know it's not as if he's constantly
talking about it
whereas there are themes that he is more
constantly talking about this is a great
example to by the way you know I
mentioned a little bit earlier I'm not
into the esoteric and I'm not into
esotericism as a way of doing philosophy
and reading past philosophical thinkers
I think that if you want to you know
read a thinker you know if they say over
and over again this is really really
important you take those things as being
really important and you don't take the
odd reference over here over here made
you know a few once or a few times as
being the centrally important thing so
alright let's see what else have we got
I'm gonna take this one by mr. Dharam
paaji what is the best advice to succeed
as a PhD student of philosophy so there
there isn't any best advice because
different PhD students are in different
programs and are faced with different
situations so there there can't be a
best advice or a best piece of advice
instead I think you could say that
there's some basic best practices some
of which may apply to your situation and
some of which may not I think one of the
things that could be the most useful is
thinking about the people that you're
going to study with don't take their
points of view on philosophy and
especially
on its history and on who's important
and who's not don't take them
uncritically as the gospel truth about
things I see so many people who do this
they're like well my instructors say bla
bla bla bla bla and you're like well
whoever told you that they knew
everything I mean why don't you look
around and see what else you could be
studying I mean if I had just gone with
what my undergraduate think my
undergraduate professors had said then I
would have you know missed out on a
whole bunch of philosophical things that
later on eh
I came to study and much of it on my own
so so there's that aspect you also want
to be able to judiciously incorporate
criticism remember that if you're in
graduate studies you're not coming in as
the you know the the smart kid who knows
everything you're coming in as somebody
who's pretty smart who's going to learn
a lot along the way and is going to
screw up things along the way so even if
your professors are kind of pricks about
the way that they give you feedback you
know it doesn't have to be a personal
thing you can say well okay
I can find some of their feedback useful
the other thing I would say is don't get
in a newsroom personal experience don't
get into jocking stuff with other grad
students about like who knows this
better you know who was studying the
most important stuff I did that myself
and I did okay in those contests because
I could think I my feet quickly and I
was I was pretty smart and I read a lot
but it was all like a total waste of
time
you know I don't I don't keep in touch
with those people anymore and what they
think about stuff doesn't concern me at
all and and except for one you know phil
dean who i still keep in touch with off
and on but he and I he and I are good
friends so you know maybe that would be
helpful in how to succeed yeah I mean
the other thing I'll say too is so if
you're a PhD student in philosophy you
will eventually have to write a
dissertation the best piece of advice I
got about dissertations came from one of
the people on Mike
mitii which I didn't actually listen to
but I now realizes really great advice
the only good dissertation is a done
dissertation don't try to do the the you
know next amazing piece of literature
because you're not going to you know
don't pick a sexy topic that everybody's
talking about this year because they
won't be talking about it next year pick
something that's manageable problem some
issue and just write your dissertation
about that it had done and then use the
skills that you've learned about
research to write your next book which
you actually will care more about write
your dissertation is your first book if
you turn it into your pet project as I
did then you wind up with something
that's too large to be to be publishable
and needs a lot of work and could
probably be split into three books but
I'm not going to do that with like you
know it's been almost almost 20 years
since I since I did my dissertation all
right here's a good question from Jeff
Sullivan many people are reading the
plague recently but there are are there
any other philosophical works you think
are particularly relevant to our time
thinking of finally giving Dostoevsky x'
demons a read thanks yeah it's funny
that people are buying up the plague as
if that's like super relevant to
everything that's that's going on right
now I mean it's a great book and I love
Camus but I think a lot of people are
gonna be disappointed as they're reading
it because and a lot of people are gonna
buy it put it on read a little bit of it
and put it on their shelves and that's
gonna be that's gonna be yeah so you
know same thing by the way happened when
Trump got elected with khana rents the
origins of totalitarianism everyone's
like oh I got to read this great book
and I you know I've read the origins of
totalitarianism several times through
and I really like a rant and I was like
oh yeah you don't want to buy that you
know that that's a tough book that's
that's a pretty dry stuff okay so are
there other stuff that's particularly
relevant to our own time so I'm gonna
give you I'm gonna give you two answers
to that one
everything is still relevant as it was
yesterday
you know there's I forget which st. they
asked about this and they said if you
were gonna find out that you were gonna
die in an hour what would you do and the
purpose of me asking this Saint thought
you know you know they'd like I'd get on
the phone and call my my parents or I'd
like you know immediately start praying
and and setting you know doing whatever
I can to atone for my sins and the saint
was like I wouldn't do anything
differently than I'm doing now I mean if
it if I'm actually doing the right thing
right now
then it doesn't matter if I'm in a
crisis situation I'm not gonna change
course you know so I think the same sort
of thing can be said about reading you
know we read Plato's works and we read
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics and we
read epictetus as discourses and we read
Cicero's on the ends and I go all the
way through write all that stuff remains
just as valuable right now and you know
you then you apply it to the situation
that you're in so for example in
thinking about the nature of justice
which you can do by reading you know WD
Ross is the right and the good or you
could think about it in terms of
utilitarianism or you could read Cicero
or you can read Aristotle going outside
when you know that you might be
endangering other people it's the wrong
thing to do and you can find all sorts
of discussions in general that would
then apply to that right now is there
anything that that's particularly good
to read during during times of sickness
that has to do with our situation
structurally I guess I mean some of
Philip dicks novels might be interesting
or helpful but I don't know that we need
to read things fictionally particularly
about plague times I mean there are some
good epidemiological stuff out there's a
great book I had years and years ago
called plagues and people that I
remember reading and enjoying and helped
put some things into perspective and by
the way Dostoevsky is demons or the
possessed
I think that's Dostoyevsky's best work
but that's my view a lot of other people
brothers karmas
for you know crime and punishment but I
really do think the demons is is his
best work all right let's see what we
get
here skip down a little bit there's a
lot of questions here so creative
retrieval what does our attitudes
towards our distributed lives now tell
us about how and whether we've been
living a technologically and framed life
not sure what distributed means and that
in that situation we are living a
technologically and framed life if we
weren't you couldn't watch me right here
right now right I rely on you know this
this Mac that I'm working on the
keyboard of which was getting kind of
wonky these days I hope it doesn't go
out because Apple Genius bars of course
are closed and my iPhone I rely on those
incredibly heavily and that's allowed me
to continue engaging with people and
teaching my classes to my academic
students and working with clients and
you know so maybe maybe you know what
you're asking about is now that we're
all inside do we see that we're more
technologically and framed that can be
driven home to some people but I mean
this is so this is something I said I
used to do these these things called
dotted like the Technosphere videos and
you just put it in you can you can find
them they're all you know from quite a
ways before I didn't do any since I
moved here to Milwaukee they're all from
when I was in New York I think I called
them Technosphere reflections one of the
things I realized back in the early 2000
you know like around 2009/2010 was like
it or not that the breakdown between
like the virtual world and the actual
world the actual world is now permeated
with the virtual world and there's you
know unless the whole internet goes down
there's no way around that now it was
permeated already by all sorts of other
technology I mean look at these
bookshelves right these came from Ikea
they're prefab
every one of these books was printed
well except for some very old ones you
know they're printed on nowadays sort of
technological devices that are run by
computers and before that it was you
know other technology the printing press
and you know so we're not outside of
technological and framing it's just a
question of what did you know what kind
of technology it is and how it permeates
things and how we use of how we
conceptualize it whether we sort of swim
like the fish in the water who can't
realize that they're in it or whether we
do the technological optimism of oh my
god this is this new iPhone is gonna
change my life entirely right or whether
we're more critical and careful about it
so all right storm Slayer you might get
asked this a lot but is it too late to
start studying philosophy from scratch
at twenty how long will it take me to
understand philosophers like Heidegger
to loser Hegel it's not too late at
twenty it's not too late at sixty I mean
Epicurus says writes that too late at in
all Dage it's a it's always a good time
to start studying philosophy and
understanding there's different levels
and different layers of understanding
depends on what you're asking about and
there isn't there is no like numerical
answer for that it depends on how much
time you put in and how much thought you
you do and what approach you take
reading philosophy will not be read like
reading you know technical manuals or
learning how to code or something like
that it's way more complex there's a lot
more ambiguity you have to read and
reread so I can't I can't give you a
prediction about how long it'll take you
to understand
Heidegger or even one of Heidegger's
works like say how long will it take you
to understand what is metaphysics an
understanding is a cumulative process
you know I understand more about
Heidegger today than I did five years
ago than I did ten years ago that I did
when I first encountered him in graduate
school like say in 1997 1796
understanding is not something that you
know understanding is not mastery
understanding is not certification
understanding is this this deepening
process that goes on and the other thing
I'll say too is as you understand one
philosopher in order to understand
Heidegger
you do need to understand some some
Aristotle and some Plato and some
Augustine and some Hegel because
Heidegger thinks that Hegel is quite
important and some Nietzsche and some
other people and in return it's not as
if first you know master these people
and then you can like move on to the
next thing
understanding Heidegger is also gonna
help you really stop you know so when
Heidegger says that Aristotle's rhetoric
book two is a hermeneutic of design well
that's not in the Aristotle but it helps
you re you know re understand what's
going on in Aristotle's so all right uh
Vitaly says are you familiar with
esoteric Gnostic mystic material looks
like many thinkers of the 19th century
like Goethe nature were affected by them
also Carl Jung was really interested in
that yeah I'm familiar with plenty of
that stuff and I did plenty of digging
into it when I was an undergrad and grad
student and I my general view was a lot
of it was nonsense and and a waste of my
time
a lot of people get into it I think for
cuz it satisfies some sort of emotional
need you know Gnostics most of the the
people who were self-described as
Gnostics who I've met and I've met quite
a few in my time typically have this
like I'm in the know and everybody else
is a dummy kind of thing you know
Hansie owners by the way I'm looking
over there because I've got his book
right there about the Gnostic religion
he's got this great discussion of
existentialism in the end where you know
he looks at you know classical nastic
stuff that he's spent the entire time
unpacking
by the way student of Heidegger you know
and then he talks about current
existentialism and he says this is a
tendency and existentialism thinking
that like were the elite we know more
than everybody else was Nietzsche
drastically affected by them no not
really I know I know there's like an
interpretation of Nietzsche out there
that says that was Goethe yeah to some
degree and not that much I mean you know
when you look at Faustus or you know the
like you know the
dr. and what is it whatever it is farm
and they are all right they're not you
don't have to understand that sort of
stuff now if you're like a Stein Aryan
anthroposophy
well you're gonna be really into that
and that's how you're gonna read Goethe
and Nietzsche but that's not the
majority view and scholarship on that
and Carl Jung was affected by that and
for me that makes Carl Jung Lissa what
do you do you know that is what it is
for me Johann says I just got done
reading MacIntyre after virtue don't
really get his view of human nature and
how he solves the criticism of
essentialism is it possible without
essentialism he never mentions
essentialism in the book as far as I
know so I'm not sure where you're
getting this is from some gloss on
MacIntyre that you're getting somewhere
else I think right you don't get his
view on human nature human nature is
complex and developmental I mean it's
it's partly revealed to us in an
Aristotelian framework but we need to go
beyond the Aristotelian framework which
is what exactly what the Aristotelian
framework properly applied would require
us to do is you know I think you want to
you probably want to reread and you want
to go on and read the rest of the what's
the equivalent of a trilogy qua tyranny
of whose justice which rationality which
builds on after virtue in which you
might actually mention essentialism but
it's it's not it's not a term that I
recall ever having seen in that work and
then three rival versions and dependent
rational animals but I mean McIntyre's
view on human nature I view it as quite
you know it's it's what Aristotle would
be doing where he around today and it's
what you know people like Lacan who
MacIntyre by the way it was quite
interested in and presumably still has
he's not dead right I would have to say
about that so
all right let's see what else we've got
going on here I just skipped again a
little bit here it's bouncing around
even more here we go rap I recently
finished Crime and Punishment have been
thinking about murder lately as morbid
as it sounds you have any
recommendations on philosophers who've
written about murder well yeah sure I
mean many of them have throughout
history
Aristotle actually talks about that is
one of the things that there is no
proper meaning for it nikka mckay and
ethics right there was lots of
discussions about killing and murder
running throughout the history of
philosophy so I don't I mean and and you
know if you want a philosopher who
people are now reading today who
originally said that suicide was the
problem posed by the absurd and now
murder is the problem posed by the
absurd read Albert Camus was the rebel
because that's what he says in his
introduction right that's how we've
thought evolved and you know the rebel
like a lot of Camus stuff it is good
philosophy but you got to kind of wade
through his style it's not for everybody
so Maxwell have you found much
philosophical value in Shakespeare's
plays what do you think is Shakespeare's
unique contribution of the history of
thought that's a good question I haven't
been able to spend time reading
Shakespeare for many years as a matter
of fact I haven't read a Shakespeare
play since we moved here to Milwaukee
now that I think about it and I do have
my dad's old collected works of William
Shakespeare one of the things I
inherited from him he was he was very
into that you know on the super fine
print on the very thin paper I should
probably go back and read it you know I
really did enjoy reading Shakespeare's
plays and puttered around with with his
sonnets as well I
that Shakespeare you know this M is not
like my idea this is something I'm
basically getting from from Bohr
hastened from Bakhtin Shakespeare is
kind of similar to Dostoevsky and that
he's a what bakhtin mikhail bakhtin
calls a poly semuc author there's a lot
of ethical ideas being worked out but
there's no like place where you can say
this is Shakespeare saying this right
here this character stands for him it's
rather in the way in which he structures
things that it works out that way and I
think you can say similar things to by
the way of Sophocles in many cases maybe
even a solace to you Ripa DS I'm not
sure Hey Bruce glad to see you here as
well thanks all right um
Zack asked what are some great Hispanic
philosophers to start reading I want to
get involved in reading more Spanish and
I've only begun with Miguel de Unamuno
and will soon start Ortega y Gasset so
I'm not I'm not a great person to ask
about this in parks that won't know more
than I enjoy Ortega y Gasset somebody
else you should check out is maria
zambrano
interesting phenomenologist and games
and things like that you know I don't
really know Spanish literature very well
so I can't I can't make any decent
recommendations maybe some other people
can weigh in and the thread if you read
down below oh Calypso which book or
books of the Bible do you find most
insightful or enjoyable to read well
this will not be a surprise to anybody
the wisdom literature right by the way
there's a really great book a classic
work on the wisdom literature by Gerhart
from rod I think it's just called the
wisdom literature and he talks about it
as being the philosophy of you know the
ancient Jewish writers so you know what
is the wisdom literature comprise quite
a few books that are that are canonical
for both all the early churches and
Protestants like book of Proverbs book a
job which is essentially a philosophical
dialogue
ecclesiastes song of songs the psalms
are part of the wisdom literature as a
matter of fact there was a long-standing
tradition that the Psalms were
essentially the fifth gospel because
every single you know thing was supposed
to be both about Christ
it was also supposed to be about every
single possible way in which the human
being could be oriented towards God
emotionally by the way that the fifth
gospel thing mentioned in Thomas Aquinas
is commentary on the Psalms before
anybody starts saying oh I see or
something like that right then we have
you know works like sera and the Book of
Wisdom brilliant stuff really really
great stuff considered canonical for
everybody except for the Protestants
because Martin Luther narrow the Canon
of the Bible but all the all the the you
know apostolic churches have those in
their works I also I gotta admit I like
the book of Judges but it's because it's
this crazy stuff about like Samson and
you know the stuff that he was doing and
dad Brad you know Baruch and all that
it's um tell you what I don't like not
into the Apapa
apocalyptic literature I find that stuff
really kind of a you know a waste of my
time and I get people to ask me about
that that sort of stuff what are you
gonna do you know I I think you know
people who obsess about what's going on
in Daniel and ignore the say the Sermon
on the Mount have kind of got their
priorities mixed up so all right Austin
Noonan is count a phenomenologist
nope he's not although phenomenologist
have drawn upon Conte and he's well
worth studying human evolution in
regards to stoicism if everything is
faded out or we make sense of topics
like freedom choice and judgments this
is a topic of study a bit still a
trouble grasping here's here's something
you might think about and even you've
asked me about this in other places
right so to begin with faded for Stoics
doesn't mean the same thing as like
absolutely determined in everything
go away right so you got to read that
term differently and think about it this
might be helpful for you because this is
a complex topic Stoics are compatible is
right and the question with compatible
lists that we always have to ask was
well how does it actually work and
there's many different stories out there
and you got to go to the texts right and
you got to spend time with those think
about is existing in a world that's
that's more or less deterministic and
we've got this little range in which we
can actually choose things and we do
have the freedom to operate within that
and every time that we do we sort of
penetrate the determinism and move it
around a little bit and it takes sense
of it but the Stoics definitely think
that we're responsible for our actions
and you know you think about it this way
a lot of what stoicism is saying is pay
attention to what's going on in your
processes because then a little bit of
freedom that you have you can use so
that you're not just operating on
automatic right engaging in lines of
thinking that that are essentially
determined we have the opportunity to
intervene within the determinism all
right Chris I love philosophy but fine
I'm a relatively slow thinker it takes
time to get my head around new concepts
and philosophy and otherwise any advice
on remedying this yeah don't remedy it
there's nothing wrong with being a slow
thinker a lot of people being being fast
is overrated a lot of people are fast
and flashy and turns out that they don't
actually grasp the things when you you
ask them about it later on there's
nothing wrong with with taking time
everybody learns at their own pace
everybody reflects at their own pace and
ideas grow and and get brought together
into configurations at their own pace as
well you don't have to try to like live
up to some sort of schedule and the goal
for philosophy is to engage in lifelong
learning and so you know don't don't
feel bad about that and don't let other
people make you feel bad about that
you might you know think about the
example of Thomas Aquinas the you know
we've got called in his own time the da
max right and then goes on to become one
of the most brilliant thinkers of the
west of his time recognized of course by
his teacher Albert the Great but not
recognized by his classmates so all
right a disciple of rob marcus aurelius
witnessed a plague in his time what can
we learn from him it's a great punch
unto Donald Roberts and who wrote a
whole book about how to think like a
Roman Emperor and who does all sorts of
stuff about that so you know even my
friend and colleague he could answer
that much better and I would look him up
X have I thought about writing a book
and stoicism is so what what type yeah
I've thought about it also talked about
it quite a bit I have a couple irons in
the fire I'm working on a book you know
look on stoicism and anger which I may
be co-writing with a friend and
colleague and you know I've got a few
other projects ongoing as well mostly
they you know I'm shooting videos so but
eventually I do need to buckle down
little yell asks do you actually enjoy
reading philosophy do you only care
about the thoughts contained Kierkegaard
versus literal question I guess I find
what's real boring for the most part but
I but I read them because you know you
got to take a medicine it's important
sometimes I enjoy reading philosophy but
I enjoy I enjoy reading and I've been
you know conversing with these people to
use Machiavelli's view or his his way of
looking at these things
if you don't know Machiavelli had a day
job and then he'd come home change his
clothes into like the robes of the
Ancients and he'd go into his study and
then he would like have his
conversations with Livy and the other
ancient historians about the nature of
politics so I I you know I really enjoy
reading philosophy when it comes to
reading a lot of the classic thinkers I
don't find reading a lot of
you know contemporary philosophy
particularly enjoyable just sometimes
because the writers are a little bit too
precious or they don't seem to be
well-informed enough about what they're
writing about you know they have a very
narrow view on things and background but
I do enjoy you know I there there's
times where I read some of my colleagues
stuff and I'm like oh man this is really
awesome stuff you know so you know some
prime examples right nobody reads
Becker's a new stoicism for its style
all right but it's a great book and
Becker is brilliant somebody else who
would where as where is it I must have
taken it down my colleague Chris Gill I
like reading his stuff quite a bit right
he's definitely worth worth checking out
but I don't know where I think it's
around here somewhere so I think it
varies quite a bit all right let's see
Leila you recently did video on George
Dickey can you say something about what
he thought about aesthetic evaluation
thank you
not an expert on Dickey I only only did
that stuff for my ethics for artists and
designers class to give us some ideas
about what is art I can't say that I've
you know read through his works very
much I was interested primarily in his
his art world theory of art that he's
eaten by the way he didn't originate
donto originated that so I I don't
probably I probably don't know enough
about it to say much competent on there
Shabnam Singla any advice for a college
philosophy major when one one starts to
question the importance of academic
philosophy and actually changing the
real world yeah don't don't expect
academic philosophy to actually change
the real-world applications of academic
philosophy can go out there and change
the real world but but philosophy by
itself isn't going to do that nor is
sociology nor is history nor is you know
studying code or any of this sort of
stuff it's all what we do with it right
so don't don't set the bar so high I
would say and realize that the Opera
what matters most is if you want to do
something with philosophy in a very
practical way you have to create
opportunities you have to make contacts
with people you have to learn how to
take philosophical ideas and communicate
them effectively to ordinary people
or there they're really not going to
give you a hearing and that's where I've
seen most of my academic colleagues
failing a lot of them don't even like
that you know they they view that as
debasing the philosophical coinage or
they're kind of afraid of doing it you
know it's interesting I remember a
colleague who I wanted to have a
sit-down interview with years and years
back and the day of the interview he had
to cancel and he was like shaking right
and I was what's wrong with you man and
he's like well this idea of being on
video and like maybe saying something
that I would get wrong and and everybody
in the world seeing it was like first of
all nobody not everybody in the world is
gonna watch this video it's but it's not
that big of a deal you know you you know
you got a like if you're gonna break
into doing this sort of thing you gotta
like develop a little tougher skin so
you know I would say those are those are
important things and the other thing as
I was mentioning earlier whatever your
professors are saying this is the
important stuff all this other stuff
isn't important they they're probably
not right about that I mean what they're
studying and teaching is probably
important but there's so much that's
worth studying out there then you don't
want to just go by what what they say
can be done there's so many people that
that set you know very narrow
restrictions on what's possible all
right solidus what's the dialect of
Conn's German I'm deliberating to learn
German after my Latin education and I
did your German went into a significant
change in the 20th century I don't think
on has a dialect
I think he's writing in High German
maybe what you're hearing is like the
aid of the tape the dative case is
sometimes getting assimilated into the
accusative but I mean it's it's it's
still the same language so I wouldn't
worry about that
I mean Conte is just hard to understand
hard to read right metallian reviewer
uses polyrhythmic poly syllables do you
have any tips for anyone trying to write
everyday is it a matter of hours it's a
matter of setting an hour and sticking
to it that's what it is right you gotta
like find a time and say that you're
actually gonna do writing at that time
that's why here in Milwaukee there's
there's a national organization that's
called shut up and write and we had it
we had a group here in in Milwaukee
obviously we're not meeting now and we
would meet at a coffee shop just a
couple blocks from here and it's
literally that you sit down and
everybody shuts the hell up and you
write for an hour and then after that
you get to chitchat about what you're
doing because if you're chit-chatting
you're not writing and a lot of people
will instead of actually writing will
make outlines and and project what
they're gonna do and the only thing to
do is to actually sit down and write
when I was working on my dissertation
the other really good bit of advice that
I got that I put into practice was 5
days a week like it or not you got to
write three pages if you want to write
more you go ahead and write more but you
have to write three pages and it can be
you know this sucks I can't write
anything I've got no ideas in my head
but you got to fill up three pages and
then at the end of the week on Saturday
you go through your 15 or more pages and
you say okay one of this is is garbage
and one of this is worth keeping and if
you get like three to five pages of good
stuff out of there and you do that you
know fifty weeks out of the year that's
150 pages that's a dissertation a short
dissertation right so you know that
that's the keys is just to like decide
on a time make sure that you actually do
some writing even if you think it's
garbage or drivel you just keep on doing
it
all right Ken Roberts oh here they
actually yeah
is there anyone attract about being as
obsessively as Heidegger yeah hi to Gary
ins jean-luc Mario God without being
right people who are following on that
sort of stuff so alright and ago in my
undergrad class is reading Kant's
groundwork section one I want to give
them next some materials that critique
can't do you have any suggestions well
John Stuart Mill actually critiques
conned in utilitarianism and in my view
gets caught wrong so that could be that
could be kind of good you know he basics
so you know when it comes to the first
formulation of the categorical
imperative right there's there's two
tests basically built into that is there
what we call a contradiction in concept
or notion and is there a contradiction
in willing it or in consequences and
Mill essentially you know reinterpret
scant wrongly as saying that there there
it really is just this contradiction and
consequences and that's that's kind of a
misguided view so you can you can you
can have a critique of Conte and then
you can have a why the critique goes
wrong and that you know that's kind of
fun to do um you know WT Ross he
criticizes Kant's in the the right and
the good
he thinks that Duty is really important
but he thinks that Kant went wrong and
saying we've got like one source of duty
that we can use um all right Pedro asks
have you thought about tackling Eastern
philosophy yeah it's thought about it
but I've rejected it in part because I
don't read Sanskrit or you know poly or
classical Chinese or stuff like that I
mean when I was studying Mandarin I
basically you know
to the level of being a good beginner
but that's about as far as I got
I mean I've taught this stuff but if I'm
gonna put up videos there's probably a
lot of other people would be much better
suited to that I may have to do it
eventually but I'm gonna have to be
super careful about how I do it so I
don't screw it up you know so and
there's so much Western philosophy for
me to get to as well all right new ku TV
is teaching others the best way to learn
I find when it comes to learning
philosophy teaching ideas to myself
hopes best different people learn
different ways there isn't a best way to
learn it's it can often be quite good to
like see whether you're you're getting
things right whether you can explain it
to somebody else but there's many other
ways to learn as well and I think we
don't want to try to have a single best
that we rely on as you know the one
thing all right I'm gonna make an
exception to taking more than one person
or than one question by a person because
it's it's germane to the shirt was I
upset when McCarthy left the Packers I
wasn't upset you know with McCarthy
while he was with the Packers so I was
ecstatic when he left the Packers and so
were the Packers I mean you can see the
difference in the press conferences and
how the team operates on the field and
of course performance from the the you
know last three years with McCarthy when
he was basically a dead weight on the
team to this last season I mean thank
God he's gone and I am so surprised that
anybody wanted to hire him it's gonna be
interesting to see how he screws up
somebody else's team but you know more
power to him for those who don't know
what I'm talking about so I'm wearing my
my Packers shirt you know and McCarthy
was head coach of the Packers and did
take them to a Super Bowl but then he
allowed himself and his coaching and his
approaches to things get very stale and
he was always kind of a stick-in-the-mud
kind of guy I mean Lafleur is I really I
really like it you know as not just as a
coach
as the kind of person the ethos that he
projects so all right let's see a louche
says thanks for dedicating a lot of time
for doing what you do second thing I'm
guessing I have to scroll down to find
it here somewhere
well I don't see it so maybe maybe I'll
hide it later all right Damon asks for
lockdown reading the EKG that's like
Connor right any more thoughts on this
don't copy the math diagrams which I did
yeah I mean the the math stuff that
Lacan does is it's interesting but I
wouldn't put too much stress on it the
other thing to keep in mind is Lacan
showing off a lot of the time to his
colleagues and the wider world seminars
are always easier to read the free on
the mirror phase well there's there's
also great discussions of it in seminar
1 and seminar 2 as well right
all right mister
week me says do you think our
observations in the natural world
suggest God or can we explain the
natural exclusively through natural
reasons I'd say neither you know but I
would also say that none of us have a
comprehensive view on the natural world
and anybody who pretends to is you know
lying to you're deluded right the
natural world is incredibly complex
right is faith the best way to know God
I mean it's a way again people are
asking me a lot of these best things I'm
a pluralist you know there isn't a best
thing for human beings in a lot of cases
when there is it's usually hard to
attain and and you know complex so am
meta prog what do you think about the
carnet critique of Heidegger's
metaphysics I don't think that Carnap
actually has a critique I think Carnap
has a complaint that stems from Carnap
and his own theory of language and
verification but I don't think it
actually touches Heidegger's metaphysics
at all so you know alright um I'm coach
which secondary accounts for Hegel do
you recommend to start with I read a few
primary material from Nietzsche a few
books by Sartre but apart from it just a
couple of online courses
well you don't read Nietzsche or start
to understand Hegel you read Hegel
scholars to understand Hegel but I'm not
a secondary source kind of person I
spend most of my time with primary texts
I'm not a good person to ask about those
sorts of things I'm sure there's a lot
of literature out there about you know
like teach yourself Hegel or Hegel made
easy but I would avoid those sorts of
things because they're probably
completely wrong as a matter of fact I'm
gonna get a dig in on somebody so
there's this guy Paul Strether and we
had you know like X in 90 minutes and I
reviewed some of his books back in the
90s when they are first coming out
they're all garbage like you can't do
Descartes in 90 minutes you can't do
Nietzsche in 90 minutes you know it's a
recipe for misunderstanding what's
what's going on so what I would say is
for Hegel is before you try to read the
phenomenology go to two other books on
his
one of the lectures on the history of
philosophy you know there's the lectures
on the philosophy of history because
those are easier he's naming names and
when and then you go to the
phenomenology you'll have some some
Hegel under your belt so to speak all
right made of clay ass I was wondering
if you've read any of Katherine Malibu's
books haven't read any Katherine
Malibu's books she is actually a friend
of my wife so I probably should read
some of her books but haven't haven't
gotten to it um let's see let me find
some some new ones what Eli asked what's
Google Scholar just type it into Google
and it'll come up right Google Scholar
is this this feature of Google that's
been around for about I don't know 15
years or so you can find scholarly
articles online that Google provides for
you change my mind can Stoicism without
the metaphysics really be called
stoicism sure yeah no problem
people do it all the time and it's not
without the metaphysics you mean
stoicism without the physics but yeah I
mean there's all different ways of
understanding stoicism there's multiple
interpretations Marco's yes what what
about philosophy makes it so attractive
to you well that's an interesting
question so I mean it's not something I
think about very often these days
I've been doing philosophy in you know
academic ways and then practical ways
and I was always interested in the
practical side of philosophy since I was
an undergraduate so you know that's
starting 1990 so now we're talking about
30 years in and I had an interest in
ideas that fit you know that later on I
recognized its philosophical from the
time I was a kid so you know I found it
an attractive thing to go into I was
very fortunate in that I I was able to
study the things that I wanted to study
my professors
pretty hands laugh a lot of the time I
was in places that turned out to have
really good libraries and I was able to
find remunerative work you know for the
first 11 years of my career
no first nine years of my career I was
an assistant professor first working for
Ball State University teaching at
Indiana State Prison and their their
prison education program where they
would earn you know bachelor's degrees
and I thought you know huge variety of
philosophy and religious studies classes
there and did a lot of scholarly work as
well you know then I I was after the
prison thing ended which was you know
largely a political decision I had to
get on the job market I went down to
Fayetteville State University and I you
don't talk philosophy and critical
thinking classes I also got into
academic leadership if I had stayed
there I was ready to get early tenure
and promotion and I'd already started
running university-wide assessments and
I helped write the tenure quality
enhancement plan but I wanted to move up
to be with my my then fiancee now wife
Andie shaaka
so from that point on I started doing
more entrepreneurial stuff you know
public speaking and Couture that I love
which is not the case for many of the
people out there I feel very bad for the
current crop of graduate students so you
know what it what is attractive about
philosophy we have this - you know
essentially 2,500 year tradition of
brilliant thinking that I can read maybe
a tiny portion of you know and there's
so many great minds that I don't agree
with it entirely but I but I love
reading it if they carted is a prime
example love reading and teaching
Descartes even though I'm not a
Cartesian sometimes I talk about myself
as being a salesperson who has a product
that sells itself I just have to be able
to you know effectively communicate
about the things that we're studying and
and people latch onto it
people of all walks of life by the way
so those are some of the things that
make philosophy attractive to me Pedro
is am i okay yeah I mean I imagine
you're asking because of the corona
virus epidemic that we're facing we are
confined to this this apartment but
we're fortunate you know I'll tell you
another thing to a little bit of back
history so when I moved up from
Fayetteville North Carolina where I was
an assistant professor at Fayetteville
State University up to the Hudson Valley
in New York to be with my my then
fiancee now now wife Andie Chaka who
I've known since high school by the way
we we well she was already living there
and I moved into what is called the
carriage house apartment that's an
apartment above a garage and we lived in
400 square feet with two dogs and two
cats and all the books and built
bookshelves myself for all of us we
managed to do that for about 2011 to
2015 so four years right we did that for
four years together living in this place
which is considerably larger and much
you know nicer looking and has good you
know lighting and air and stuff like
that up on the eighth and ninth floor in
a building downtown of Milwaukee we're
doing okay we're you know I was a little
bit sick for a while my wife was quite a
bit sick she got tested doesn't have
influenza doesn't have corona we're
practicing the social distancing and the
protocols we actually just made
ourselves some some you know masks that
I'm gonna be using when I won't go walk
the dog because now it's recommended
that we wear masks whenever we go
outside we have enough food you saw
missing being able to go to the gym I am
missing getting to see my students and
that sort of thing it is kind of sad to
see our city because we live right
downtown
basically vacant
yeah we're I'm doing okay I've got more
work than I can actually get
accomplished so I I've had a few down
days but ii-i've got you know tons and
tons of things to do so I don't get
bored
my wife is an amazing cook I'm a pretty
good cook so we have good food here as
well and we're fortunate
we're both rather choleric people and
we've worked a lot on our relationship
and anger issues in the year the 10
years now that we've been together so
you know we've been in quarantine now
for over three weeks so we're doing
we're doing pretty good
I like you know it's nice to be with
somebody that you like I I'm you know
sorry for the people who are stuck with
somebody who they they don't like that
would really suck for this this
quarantine so um let's see what else
we've got it just bounced again all
right Sarah asks what are my views and
spiritual philosophy I'm not really sure
what spiritual philosophy means then she
says if I read the the bhava Gita yeah
I've read and taught the bhava Gita I
mean like I said you know when I was
teaching at Indiana State Prison I
taught religious studies classes and
that was one of the texts that we would
often refer students to so yeah unknown
asks how to metaphysical things
influenced our mindsets not really sure
because I you know are we talking about
like metaphysical ideas are we talking
about about other things I don't know
Lynden asks about Rolo Mae good to see
you Linden by the way over there in
Ireland I started reading Rollo May as
part of a reading group what do you
think of his view and Heidegger
intentionality stoicism hedonism it's
been a long time since a read Rollo it
was actually my alright role of my the
stuff that I read I liked but I don't
remember enough about what he
to say I should probably go back to it
that you know you should uh you should
write me because you know where to find
me and tell me about this reading group
and about about your thoughts because
I'd be interested to see what you have
to say about that alright um room nine
podcast that is one of my favorite
things about having only a high school
diploma I've had conversations so many
were stuck in the ideas of their
professors I I think you're referencing
what I was saying before about like your
professors at any given place have a lot
of ideas about what's important and
what's not now I mean you could easily
have a high school education and be
stuck in all sorts of other people's
ideas of what's important and what's not
as well could be a no you you know
YouTube host or Instagram influence or
whatever you want or your boss or you
know your your crazy uncle or so I don't
know that that you know simply having a
high school education helps out in that
respect I think it's a more personal
thing about whether you you like you
know whether you you take in a wide
variety of voices right alright Sean
Kelly critical thinking question where
do you place abductive reasoning with
deduction and induction okay so this is
a little bit of a technical thing
oftentimes when we're teaching about
argument we distinguish between
deductive and inductive arguments
deductive arguments are you know way
ideally they work is if the premises are
true the conclusion must be true if it's
a valid deductive argument right now
ideally we want the premises to be true
sometimes they're not and then we say
that it's an unsound argument so there's
two ways deductive arguments can can
fail inductive arguments are not in
terms of valid or invalid they're weak
or strong they're they're based on you
know is inductive rather than deductive
and actually a lot of times when we're
doing garbage science where we're
proceeding deductive Lee rather than
inductively but abduction is something a
little bit different and the place that
you would want to go for you know sort
of the classic discussion of this is
Charles Sanders purses works and
he's and also you know another person
I'm looking up there because his works
are up there another person was really
good about discussing this is Umberto
Eco by the way because it turns out to
play a very important role in semi in
semiotic srate which again Charles had a
purse big big early person in semiotics
so am deductive arguments work in a
different way and and you know quite a
few of the arguments that we make and
oftentimes it's called inference to the
best explanation will be abductive it's
not the same thing as deductive or
inductive it's a third kind of inference
and so that I mean that's where I sit at
it and I think that we need all three of
these working together so yeah all right
seek no honors do you think we have free
will depends entirely and what I mean by
free will do I think we can like snap
our fingers every time and pull
ourselves up by our bootstraps and
always choose the right thing no matter
what no I don't think and I don't think
that most of the people in the history
of philosophy who think that we have
free wills think that instead I think
you know it's very complicated and as
somebody was asking a little bit earlier
I'm blanking on exactly who it was we do
have to be able to account for how does
how does a free will work within a
largely deterministic universe so yeah
Sarah asks what are my views on capital
punishment and I read thoughts on the
guillotine by Camus yeah reflections on
the gates yeah I've read I've read that
stuff and I think the capital punishment
can be warranted and in some cases and
even needed I also think that the way
that we do it here in the United States
reasons and then once we do condemn
somebody to to the death penalty which
we have in some of our states
they often languish for years and years
and years before it actually happens
which you know offers the opportunity
for them to become a very different
person than the person who committed the
crime so all right Kyle asked what's my
thoughts on the Frankfurt School feeling
really into some of that
the Adorno although I find him
incredibly difficult to write on
I've always enjoyed reading his work and
Horkheimer is pretty cool too and and
and you know mark ooza is this weird
wacky wild guy I don't really like erich
fromm that much I've always found him a
little bit sort of superficial but maybe
I'll go back and check him out again
sometime in the future and and you know
whether habermas really is a frankfurt
school person or not is i don't think i
think can it debatable he certainly
draws upon them but i don't think that
he's this will probably be a
controversial opinion i don't know i
don't think he fits in quite as well
with with them all right uh Mark Trumbo
hey Mark nice to see ya do I think that
Plato took the chariot metaphor found in
the Phaedrus from the Parmenides poem I
do not as a matter of fact I think that
they're structurally two totally
different things I don't I don't think
that that he took it from Parmenides I
mean I hear I'm just sort of speculating
I don't know I mean you know did any of
us know about that so yeah all right bye
ringin what are my thoughts on
perennialism the distillation of all
religions - one forgotten one I think
that's wishful thinking nonsense that
there's no historical basis for and I
think it's kind of you know I think it
overlooks I think what it does is it
takes such selective views and what's
important in religions that I just don't
buy it I'm more of a pluralist that way
and I think that it's important when we
talk about religions to actually to
attend not to what we'd like them to be
but what what they you know what they
present themselves as phenomenologically
so I don't really buy that
um oh man ron has a tough question here
my fiance has currently had a funeral
where there's many people friends and
family no one was wearing a mask or
their protective gear do you think it
was justified to tell her not to attend
totally justified that is really
imprudent to them not to do that at this
point in time and not only imprudent but
unjust you should not be imposing the
chance of getting a illness which is
killing many people even people who are
not immune compromised there is no call
for doing that
you know funerals are an important part
of our life but there's ways to do it do
it right you know people really lack a
sense of proportion and I think and I
hope she listened to you probably not
right because you say she's currently at
the funeral but you were right to tell
her not to do that you know all right
it's GT baby just stopping by to say I
love your channel help me throughout my
college course of ancient philosophy
well that's very nice to read I'm glad
it was helpful for you all right did you
so TMI says have you read Romanian
moralist Emil Chiron he was
distinctively against being called the
philosopher though he's part of the post
modernist post modernist current
nonetheless if so what did you think
haven't really read him other than
little bits and pieces here so I don't
have a view on him
Breezie free what are your thoughts on
languages deviation from referencing the
external or objective to effectively
communicate and the seemingly natural
tendency towards dealing and abstraction
and ethics not exactly sure what's being
asked there but
I mean that seems to be part of what
language does it abstracts right and
every language has ethical terminology
built into it that people use so yeah
let's see ah Marcus given the social
isolation experienced by many what if
anything could be of interest from the
desert fathers and other hermit
traditions oh you know you could you
could read around in the desert fathers
it depends on what you want to do with
your time you know if what you want to
do is like watch Netflix and eat chips
and you know stuff like that I don't
think they'll be very helpful for you if
you want to try to use them the time to
make spiritual progress then reading
John Cassian or you know as I grew
espantoso people like that would
probably be pretty good
Damon Forbes says Aristotle says the
brain is not fit for learning until 25
Aristotle doesn't say that as a matter
of fact he didn't think the brain did
the thinking he thought the heart did
that so Aristotle definitely doesn't say
that that said he thought that when it
comes to matters of ethics were not
completely fit for for understanding it
as a matter of fact a lot of people
after 25 because he says the immaturity
can be in ears or in the way in which
people behave but he thought young
people could learn all sorts of things
before they are 25 mathematics is a
prime example so yeah alright I mean we
got about 15 minutes left so there's a
lot of people asking multiple questions
here and getting into conversations
about they guillotine I'm gonna skip
over all of that
boogie reverie asks an interesting
question what sort of musical companions
have you turned to during this
quarantine the same ones that I always
do you know I'm a big metalhead I may
have mentioned well some of you may have
heard me talk as I did mention it in my
update video that I'm gonna be doing a
classic metal I haven't decided whether
to call it you know
or class or there was another c-word
that I thought about using I can't
remember offhand but uh you know I I'm
gonna be doing some stuff with that and
some interesting you know presentation
and discussion my wife is a much more
you know broad musical palette you could
say as a matter of fact I don't know a
single type of music that she actually
doesn't like and so we are listening to
some stuff yesterday a lot a lot of cool
stuff that she you know turns me on to
and you know last night I actually got
my banner out and started playing a bit
I play and sing I also have my my used
to be my base I give it to my daughter
and now she's still housed here that I
might start playing as well and you know
last night I played some Bill Withers
banjo played some cracker and some Duran
Duran and what else did I play some
Coldplay you know I've got kind of
eclectic tastes when it comes to that
and the scorpions big city nights so you
know all right key and Sarah do you
recommend any particular deontologist to
read well you definitely want to read
count right he is sort of like the big
daddy of the day I talk just so you
never want to deprive yourself from
reading him dark sky imagine right now
statistically there are dozens of people
as brilliant as Socrates nature hiding
or light right now they've a mail
address and they breathe the air at same
air there's us right now yeah probably
the case so all right
let's scroll down a bit
a lot of back and forth here
Oh Nathan Orman has a good clarification
when I was talking about Gerhard fine
rod yes it is wisdom in Israel that is
the name of the book that he wrote about
the wisdom literature really classic
commentary and sort of interpretation of
the biblical wisdom literature I like I
like fun rod I'm a big fan of his all
right let's see here
got about 12 minutes before I got to get
off and start doing some other work
Kristina Nash says kochia nism
utilitarianism or virtue theory which is
the one you think some we as a society
should practice more of I'm a virtue
ethicist now that's sad you know
somebody I look up to quite a bit and
had the opportunity to study with and
formed a friendship with Alastair
McIntyre he's very clear that that
virtue ethics had better incorporate
some stuff from Conte and mill Hecht
that virtue ethics had not been done in
this sort of abstract way where it's
like one of three options or something
like that virtue ethics the real
strength of it is being able to take in
stuff from rival traditions and make
sense of it kind of look in the town and
say I can grand the book right up right
up here on the bookshelf right you see
that ethics in politics there's an essay
in there by MacIntyre making that very
point right so Caleb says recently
stumbled on your lectures on Kierkegaard
do you think Kierkegaard still has
valuable insight for compote religion in
2020 not true a compote religion as
there's any clarifications I don't see
that will just say religion right yeah
kick regards always relevant
I mean his emphasis on
all subjectivity and the you know the
fact that we can't always communicate
things to everybody else and make that
the criterion for what we buy into and
his discussions in you know my favorite
work by him philosophical fragments I
think that's that's you know I don't
want I don't want to say the best work
but that's my favorite work because it
deals with this this intrusion of the
divine and the eternal into time in ways
that we human beings could make sense of
it all right even where can I get
started with learning philosophy good
question Plato Plato is a great place to
start
get yourself some Platonic dialogues you
don't even have to buy them they're
available online
you know just type in Plato dialogues
and there's plenty of websites where you
can find it I always say is start with
Plato you don't just stick with Plato
but the Plato is a great starting point
because so many other philosophers are
gonna be referencing him right and the
dialogues are sometimes aggravating but
but also quite fun and and so you know
that that's helpful
alright here's a good question from odd
tor do you think Vic and Stein destroyed
philosophy as a whole is analytic
tradition is very harsh as ordinary
language philosophy Vic and I did not
destroy people are always saying
philosophies dead so and so did this and
they do their with Heidegger too you
know can't do metaphysics after
Heidegger nonsense I mean how would the
same thing with contrite I can't made
this Copernican turn we're all post
conscience now that's [ __ ] you know
there's no there's no one single person
here like did that to philosophy it's
not Hegel either by the way Nietzsche
right you know there's plenty of people
out there pushing these narratives and
they always have an agenda when they
push these narratives it usually
involves them doing the important kind
of philosophy so don't buy into that
sort of stuff philosophy is doing fine
and and you know many people are you
know these no that's not say don't read
Vick and should I there's some
interesting insights there you know the
whole language game form a life thing
languages use all of that although quite
a bit of that you can get from other
thinkers as well
outside of the analytic tradition so all
right uh let's see here dudu Oh James
asks have you read all the Doon books if
so which ones are your favorite I have
not
if you mean have I read all the Doon
books that Frank Herbert himself wrote
yeah but I mean his son is like his son
has really made an industry out of
publishing stuff afterwards right it's
to kind of go a little bit downhill I
would say all right Kyle asks what's
your thoughts on philosophers and an
artist hanging out do you have any
experience of fruitful crossovers well
it's interesting you would ask that I
actually teach at Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design as the resident
philosopher there they brought me in to
develop philosophy classes for their
students so as a matter of fact a lot of
my students are artists and designers
all sorts of different majors ranging
from like fine arts illustration to
architecture to communication design and
I love working with them because they're
there's so much interesting stuff that
they bring to the table and they are
hungry for a philosophy let me tell you
and you know I like my colleagues there
as well that's not the first time that
I've ever interacted with artists as a
matter of fact my very first job in
college as a student was working with
the art department both as a carpenter
and as a docent and then as an artist
model and I kept working with them
throughout my time in in college you
know not the docent part but but you
know I'd do other stuff with them and I
got pretty close with them so yeah I was
you know working with artists quite a
bit and then in graduate school I had
quite a few friends who are artists and
I've always you know every place that
I've taught I've known some fine arts
colleagues that I've had some good
relationships with particularly you know
at FSU
so you know and then you know we can
answer that as well because of my wife's
connections the culinary connections a
lot of people don't think of you know
culinary and baking and pastry is art
work but it really is it's the art that
you you consume in the process and so
I've had a lot of great you know
interactions and conversations with them
as well so all right here is a very
practical question by Corbeau should the
United States block respirator exports
to Canada if so Quebec would lose a year
worth of respirators our nurses are in
panic mode no I think I think you know
90% of the stuff that the Trump
administration is doing right now is
posturing and you know usually driven by
greed and stupidity and vanity we should
be coordinating our efforts with Canada
we should be thinking you know there
should be a coordinated effort across
the United States to be givethe there
shouldn't be any this biessed subletting
governors you know like in Florida or
Mississippi rescind orders and let
people go back to church or any of the
sort of stuff we shouldn't have Hobby
Lobby opening up you know stores again
after being told that they need to close
them down all of that stuff should be
you know go on right and we should be
coordinating across the continent
instead we're doing this this stupid you
know don't believe the experts driven by
nationalism and and you know trying to
win another election sort of garbage
that's that's going on I hope to god
that they don't cut you off and yeah
Quebec would would would be in quite a
bit of trouble so that's about all I
have to say about that xeno says does
anyone read your journey to the end of
nights it's good reads by louis
ferdinand saline and i will say i
certainly have and i loved it
that said it's probably the only book by
so lean that i actually like and i
haven't read it for a very long time so
all right I can't read Cyrillic writing
so I'm not sure how to pronounce this
person's name please post more lectures
on philosophy and science fiction so
interesting informant
yeah that's that's one of the things
that's kind of gone by the wayside for
right now right because we can't meet in
person for the worlds of speculative
fiction series unfortunate once I get
caught up enough on other work I think I
might start doing some some online
events about philosophy and science
fiction but that's probably not going to
happen in April I got so much class
related stuff I got to take care of and
I'm doing a lot of ethics consulting and
also you know the work with stoicism
today is also consuming quite a bit of
time so we will do something and we're
probably gonna be a quarantine for quite
a while so I'll do something but I don't
know when all right let me see if I can
find something good to go out on we got
about three minutes left before I got to
get to other work
[Music]
[Music]
well here's a quick one to knock out
stergo do you plan to make videos about
rhetoric or Aristotle's Organon I
already did
I did videos on Aristotle's categories
but will I make videos about the
rhetoric probably and then you know
topics would be cool to do as well not
super high on my priority list right now
but yeah let's see what else we got here
it just jumped did you do do oh here's
here's an interesting one
so says this is from nakusha I'm reading
michel foucault is the order of things
do you have any thoughts on this book
and how to approach it that is a blast
from the past right yeah that that's a
cool book by Foucault Foucault at one
point like said I am NOT a structuralist
[ __ ] he is a structuralist in that
book you can actually take grimaces aham
glasses semiotic square and take fucose
presentations of things in that book and
you can fit them into the square
easy-peasy right and and it is an
incredibly structuralist work it's it's
an early work it's part of what you know
is what we call this archaeological time
as opposed to genealogical time and I
love it I I really enjoyed the order of
things a lot of people just skip over it
but it's it's worth checking out reading
the archaeology of knowledge can help
with it the other thing to keep in mind
and this goes in general for free called
Foucault is an interesting historian
donat don't--don't uncritically trust
his takes on things
he always has interesting things to say
and he is very often painstaking but he
is constructing a narrative and that
narrative is usually a lot cleaner than
the real texts seem to say I would also
- about the history of sexuality in
ancient philosophy don't place too much
trust in in fuko's interpretation of say
Seneca or Aristotle there you know when
you read it as somebody who does ancient
philosophy or like well this is
insightful but about twenty percent of
this is you know just unsupportable
[ __ ] and you got to be able to
distinguish the two of them from each
other so alright I am going to bring
this to a close thanks so much for all
of your questions I'm glad we got to
spend a little time together on this for
me Saturday afternoon I've got some work
I've got to get to now mostly having to
do with my academic students and classes
so we'll be having some other online
events you know best place to find those
is on the reason I Oh calm events
calendar my Facebook page you know you
can find me and in Twitter as well I'm
always posting about stuff there so hope
all of you are safe and stay so and stay
healthy and you know nobody knows what's
going to happen in the next couple
months anybody tries to tell you that
they they do know exactly what's gonna
happen is is probably got some sort of
agenda or they or they they're unduly
you know optimistic about their own
ability to read the future so alright
that brings it to a close I'll see you
somewhere in the ether